vem com meu eu quero te mostrar um
caminho pra saúde encontrar no canal do
além do TR Universo de saúde natural
remédios naturais dicas incríveis cuide
de você de forma simples visível vem
nessa compartilhar espalha a
notícia a saúde das pessoas merece
atenção e
[Música]
delícia compartilhe os vídeos faça bem a
vida de alguém pode mudar também no
canal da t Alé
dovar Viva Saúde natural vamos juntos se
desenvolv
[Música]
os vídeos faço bem a vida de alguém pode
mudar também no canal do d além do TR se
envolva Viva Saúde natural vamos juntos
se desenvolva
[Música]
Eu tenho um canal de saúde mais completo
do YouTube conheça e se inscreva Você já
se decepcionou com a forma como a
medicina é praticada nos dias de hoje eu
sou Dr Alan Machado Dutra ensino sobre
as medicinas personalizada de precisão e
feita da maneira mais natural possível
essa forma de enxergar vai na raiz dos
problemas na origem dos Mentos isso é o
contrário da Medicina Ortodoxa mais
convencional com a qual você está
acostumado que simplesmente atua somente
nos sintomas e não corrige a fonte das
doenças conheça nossos vídeos sobre
alimentação saudável gerenciamento do
envelhecimento além de várias doenças
específicas assine o canal e tem acesso
as informações valiosas para você e sua
família
[Música]
Olá minhas amigas meus amigos estou
muito feliz de estar aqui com vocês
novamente estamos inaugurando hoje um
modelo novo de Live que nós vamos chamar
de mini Live Então meus amigos feras
então estamos inaugurando esse novo
modelo que vai ser 20 minutos de
Exposição eu vou ser o mais claro mais
objetivo possível e depois eu vou
responder às dúvidas exatamente por 10
minutos hoje nós temos uma live muito
importante
muito
necessária e a intenção é ser bastante
dinâmico para que as pessoas que possam
assistir depois que não estejam
assistindo ao vivo não desistam de
assistir até o final Então vamos falar
sobre o tema de grande importância Tá
novamente alta no cenário global que é a
emergência de saúde na ming pox ou
varelo do macaco ou
mipox então vocês sabem que 2022 houve o
problema nessa direção e agora voltou
esse ano de 2024 então em um mundo que
ainda está se recuperando das Profundas
cicatrizes deixadas aí dos últimos 3
anos né Vocês sabem do que eu tô falando
nos vemos novamente diante de um desafio
que a Organização Mundial de Saúde
classificou como uma emergência de saúde
Global sim o mipox ou monkeypox embora
não seja uma doença nova ela tem causado
preocupação
devido a sua recente
disseminação e também devido à novas
formas de transmissão dessa doença Então
nesse objetivo hoje é esclarecer O que
exatamente está acontecendo o que que a
ciência já sabe sobre isso o que que nós
podemos fazer para nos proteger e
proteger nossos entes queridos nossas
famílias né Vamos então estabelecer aqui
uma contextualização
histórica Av varila dos Macacos não é
uma doença que surgiu agora na verdade
ela foi identificada pela pela primeira
vez nesses animais na década de
1950 década de 50 do século passado em
humano nos anos 1970 então desde então
casos esporádicos foram registrados
especialmente nas regiões de alguns
países da África no entanto o que nós
estamos vendo agora é uma nova abordagem
para essa velha conhecida então
Diferentemente do que vios no passado a
mipox de 2022 e também do ano passado
trou novas formas de
transmissão incluindo a transmissão
sexual predominantemente ocorrendo no
sexo entre homens no sexo homa afetivo
masculino mas também agora na
transmissão de pele de pessoa para
pessoa e até pela via aérea Então tá
acontecendo a disseminação em ambientes
que antes não eram considerados de risco
com um contato muito menos rtimo com o
contato eh tanto de toque quanto de
respiratório então locais como trabalho
e escolas Então por que que esse tema é
muito importante você pode estar se
perguntando por que que nós estamos
discutindo isso agora porque a
Organização Mundial de Saúde decretou
recentemente uma emergência Global sobre
essa doença o que significa que o risco
de disseminação e o impacto em escala
Global segundo essa agência já seriam
consideráveis tá então a OMS já havia
decretado um alerta máximo para essa
doença em junho de 2022 e esse status
foi rebaixado em Maio de 23 mas voltou a
ser levado a status de emergência
internacional em agosto agora de
2024 indicando o aumento da preocupação
Global então Especialmente porque a nova
variante está afetando o número maior de
crianças acredita-se que a nova Cepa que
nós chamamos de clado né umb tá um de b
de bola tem a maior transmissão por
gotícula de saliva do que a Cepa
anterior a 2B
Além disso no dia 12 de agosto de 2024 a
MS anunciou a formação de um comitê para
monitorar os casos da doença na África
destacando o potencial da Cepa atual em
causar óbitos não quer dizer que todo
mundo vai morrer Lógico que não pessoal
estamos falando aqui de 10% de
letalidade ou seja 10% das pessoas
poderiam ter esse desfecho de óbito ao
adquirir essa doença a versão anterior
era em torno de 1% Então nesse ponto é
crucial que todos nós estejamos bem
informados para poder tomar as medidas
corretas e evitar um Pânico
desnecessário eu como médico né Nós como
médicos como classe também os cientistas
e cidadãos em geral o nosso papel é
proteger a saúde pública baseado em
evidências sólidas e também dando
orientações de qualidade orientações
sólidas baseadas em evidências né então
para começar vamos entender um pouco
melhor o que que é essa doença como que
ela é transmitida o que que torna ela
uma preocupação tão grande no cenário
atual Então vamos falar um pouquinho da
natureza da doença e da sua
transmissão agora que nós entendemos a
importância desse tema vamos aprofundar
na doença em si então a varíola doss
macacos ou mipox é uma doença zoonótica
ou seja ela é transmitida Originalmente
dos Macacos é uma doença que
Originalmente veio desses animais PR os
humanos foi identificado pela primeira
vez como eu já disse em Macacos de
laboratório na década de 1950 daí o nome
mas o primeiro caso em humanos foi
registrado nos anos
1970 então desde então a doença era
considerada Rara e limitada
principalmente em regiões da África
central e da África ocidental onde esse
vírus endêmico ou seja ele está presente
de maneira meio que permanente nessas
regiões então historicamente a
transmissão essa doença se dava
principalmente através do contato direto
desses animais infectados seja por
mordida aranhão ou manuseio da carne de
caça contaminada né nas regiões onde
tinha esse hábito de caçar os macacos
então contudo a situação mudou
drasticamente nos últimos anos porque em
2022 vimos uma mudança na fma de
transmissão onde a doença passou a se
espalhar entre humanos de maneiras que
antes não eram observadas então uma das
mudanças observadas foi a transmissão
sexual que foi vista também em
2022 predominantemente entre homens que
fazem sexo com homens isso marcou um
ponto de virada na compreensão da doença
da monkeypox ampliando o risco de
infecção para além do contato com
animais introduzindo novos desafios né
para controlar essa doença então Além
disso mais recentemente o vírus começou
a ser transmitido em ambientes como
locais de trabalho e escolas o que antes
não era comum então isso significa que o
monking pox deixou de ser uma
preocupação restrita a certos grupos e
passou a representar um risco mais amplo
mais abrangente paraa população então a
nova Cepa o clado 1b de bola como eu já
disse tem uma tem uma letalidade 10% que
uma taxa significativamente maior em
relação em comparação com a ca anterior
que tinha uma letalidade por volta de 1%
Então essa CPA atual de novo um b de
bola mostrou também ser mais
transmissível do que a variante anterior
de 2022 que era a 2B de bola então houve
também uma expansão geográfica em 2024
essa nova Cepa foi detectada em 13 13
países
africanos incluindo Nações que
anteriormente não
haviam reportado o caso de monky pox
então isso indicou uma expansão
geográfica Dentro do continente africano
então o Congo especialmente notificou
mais de 15.000 casos mon ipox com 550
mortes até o momento em 2024 e o número
que é significativamente maior do que
era em 2023 vamos falar então do período
de incubação o tempo que demora entre
você pegar esse vírus e ter sintomas que
é incubação e também dos sintomas os
sintomas geralmente começam com febre
dor de cabeça dor muscular e fadiga
muito semelhante a qualquer virose que
Você já conhece porém um dos sinais mais
característicos são as lesões de pele as
lesões cutâneas que surgem em várias
partes do corpo especialmente no rosto
nas extremidades né nas mãos nos braços
na região genital em caso de transmissão
sexual essa região genital vai ficar
muito mais Evidente essas lesões então
elas podem se assemelhar a bolhas ou
espinhas grandes e contém uma alta carga
viral então se você tiver contato com
essas bolhas vai tornar o contato e a
transmissão muito mais fácil tá que é
uma das principais vias de transmissão
muito mais importante do que a via
respiratória quanto ao período de
incubação que é o tempo né como já falei
entre você ser exposto e aparecer os
sintomas varia entre 5 a 21 dias então é
bem Ah de um período assim muito
alargado de 5 a 21 dias mas em média
ocorre entre 12 a 13 dias então isso
significa que uma pessoa que possa estar
infectada e transmitindo o vírus antes
mesmo de saber que está doente então ela
pode estar transmitindo e não tá
sentindo nada o que torna o controle
mais desafiador E também o isolamento
dos casos fica mais difícil então Outro
ponto importante que eu tenho que frisar
aqui que tornou essa doença ainda mais
relevante é que a MPX pode ser
transmitida através de roupas ou de
superfícies recentemente contaminadas
então para dar uma ilustração para vocês
vamos lembrar aqui de um caso antigo um
exemplo histórico aí dos primeiros casos
registrados de bioterrorismo aliás deixa
devia nem usar essa palavra né porque o
YouTube não gosta então Houve essa esse
registro histórico quando mantas
contaminadas né pelos eh colonizadores
do continente americano eh na no caso da
América do Norte foram entregues foram
distribuídas para populações indígenas
naquela região na América do Norte e
isso acredita-se que foi uma coisa
proposital e resultou em uma alta
mortalidade então desses índios
norte-americanos Então esse é um exemplo
extremo do que eu tô dizendo mas ele
ressalta como roupas ou superfícies que
entrar em contato com lesões infectadas
pode ser uma fonte significativa de
contágio Então tome cuidado com as
roupas e utensílios que você divide com
as pessoas tá isso é uma coisa que a
gente tem que prestar bastante atenção a
partir dessa possibilidade dessa doença
começar a entrar aqui na nossa região
porém além do contato direto e indireto
também existe a possibilidade de
transmissão
respiratória especialmente através de
gotículas esperides por tosse por
espirro ou até mesmo durante conversas
próximas E isso se torna particularmente
relevante em ambientes fechados e que
também que foram mal ventilados onde o
risco de infecção aumenta então também
temos que ter esse cuidado de não
ficarmos em ambientes fechados com
muitas pessoas desconhecidas ou se é o
caso utilizar aí algum tipo de proteção
em relação a prevenção individual
diferente de outras infecções que são
potencialmente sexualmente
transmissíveis a monke boox não é
prevenida pelo uso preservativo por quê
Porque é o contato pele com pele né não
é aquela situação clássica de
eh da da de ter que ter ente contato com
as secreções então especialmente se a
pessoa que tá transmitindo tiver lesões
ao redor da região genital contato de
pele com pele já vai propiciar essa
transmissão então a prevenção se dá
nesses casos né de da pessoa se eh tomar
os cuidados de afastamento físico e pela
higienização frequente né então em
ambientes onde H suspeita ou confirmação
de casos de monkeypox o distanciamento
físico e uso de máscaras podem ser
necessários e especialmente em locais
fechados e mal ventilados tá a gente não
sabe ainda se essa doença vai entrar
firme eu espero sinceramente que não
entre firme mas se se acontecer a gente
vai provavelmente ter que tomar esses
cuidados tá então essas medidas ajudam a
prevenir a transmissão respiratória do
vírus que embora menos comum é possível
tá apesar de ser menos comum do que pele
a pele é possível por meio de cutículas
espid ao falar tosir ou espirrar Então
se alguém em casa de vocês conhecerem
tiver com essa doença é importante
manter esse afastamento mas afastamento
de 2 m tá não é uma coisa absurda e
evitar o compartilhamento de objetos
pessoais como toalhas e roupas de cama
até que todas as lesões estejam secas e
cicatrizadas né então vamos falar um
pouquinho sobre a situação atual do
Brasil e da África tá até o dia 13 de
agosto de
2024 foram registrados 709 casos de
mipox no Brasil que resultou em 16
óbitos então em comparação em 2022 foram
só 107 casos e 13 óbitos e na cidade
desculpa na no país da África que é mais
acometida no momento que é o Congo a
situação é bem diferente tem 15.000
casos e 550 óbitos registrados nesse ano
de 2024 então países vizinhos da região
lá do Congo como burundi Quênia Ruanda e
Uganda também registraram cerca de 50
casos ao longo de 2024 então a república
democrática do Congo foi a mais afetada
T teve vários aí casos milhares de casos
relatados E como eu falei mais de 500
óbitos né e a maioria foram crianças
então gente eu quero que vocês entendam
o seguinte as pessoas que estão dentro
desses 10% de letalidade geralmente São
pessoas que têm o sistema imune
comprometido de alguma maneira são
pessoas que TM doenças crônicas são
pessoas com t c metabólica que tem
obesidade que tem doença crônica não
controlada então se você mantém uma boa
saúde é a mesma história que aconteceu
há 3 4 anos atrás se você tem uma boa
saúde uma boa imunidade Você fica muito
mais protegido contra essa doença Então
vamos
entender o que nós podemos fazer para
prevenir Quais são as medidas
preventivas mais eficazes além dessas
que eu já falei que são as mais óbvias
né que aquela questão de não ter contato
direto com quem tem a doença de Em
algumas situações específicas usar
máscara eu não tô aqui falando para todo
mundo sair usando máscara que nem
aconteceu há 3 anos atrás mas eh se você
tiver num ambiente que você sai que você
tem risco Talvez algumas circunstância
Você vai precisar usar dependendo do
número de casos que nós tivemos aqui no
Brasil tá então A grande questão é como
fazer para prevenir e tratar Então essa
a próxima parte aqui da nossa mini Live
tá primeiro eu queria falar um pouquinho
mais sobre sobre a letalidade e as
complicações né sabemos agora como é que
ela é transmitida expliquei para vocês
se você perdeu depois você volta o vídeo
o vídeo vai ficar gravado Então
precisamos entender agora o quão grave
essa doença pode acontecer pode ficar né
primeiramente é importante desmistificar
algumas informações alarmistas que estão
circulando então ela não é letal em 100%
dos casos a doença obviamente falei que
é 10% já é maior do que era há 2 anos
atrás que era 1% mas ainda é 10% de
letalidade tá então toma cuidado com
algumas mensagens aí algumas manchetes
sensacionalistas que podem surgir tá
porém né porque ela não é tão letal
assim não é acima de 10% que não deve eh
ser eh colocada a devida atenção e ela
não pode ser subestimada então a
letalidade da doença da mipox vai variar
dependendo da Cepa certo e também o mais
importante ainda é das condições de
saúde da pessoa infectada por exemplo a
Cepa que circulou em 2022 era 1% já
falei isso ou seja de cada 100 pessoas
infectadas uma poderia evoluir para
óbito agora atual chamada 1b de bola é
mais preocupante porque chega até 10%
então isso significa que em cada 100
pessoas e infectadas cerca de 10 pode
evoluir para óbito especialmente já
falei mas eu vou reforçar vários
conceitos importantes aqui especialmente
aquelas pessoas que t comorbidades ou
sistemas imunológicos comprometidos
essas sim vão correr risco então
principal ponto aí manter o sistema
imune em dia tá esses 10% que vão poder
potencialmente falecer são os 10% que
tem maus hábitos de vida que tem
comorbidades tem doenças de base que vão
enfraquecer o seu sistema de defesa
enfraquecer o seu organismo a ponto
dessa pessoa ficar vulnerável ao vírus
Ok então é crucial ressaltar que os
grupos mais vulneráveis a complicações
são aqueles com doenças de base diabetes
hipertensão C metabólica que é aquela
constelação de sinais e sintomas
relacionados a alterações dos exames
principalmente aumento da glicose
aumento da do triglicérides no sangue
aumento da circunferência abdominal
aumento da pressão arterial e outras
condições crônicas que enfraquece o
sistema de defesa Então essas pessoas
são propensas então devemos evitar essas
doenças com o estilo de vida com estilo
de vida saudável que eu tanto falo no
canal então entra aqui a medicina de
estilo de vida que não apenas reduz os
riscos Associados à doença mas também
fortalece o nosso organismo contra uma
variedade de infecções não é só o Monk
hipo Mas qualquer outra infecção tá
inclusive aquela outra que a gente não
pode nem falar o nome aqui manter uma
alimentação equilibrada realizar
atividades físicas regulares gerenciar o
estresse gerenciar o sono são Pilares
muito importantes para fortalecer o
nosso tema de defesa imune E como eu
sempre digo quem leva uma vida saudável
tem maiores chances de enfrentar
qualquer doença Inclusive essa nova umok
pox vamos falar um pouco de um assunto
um pouco espinhoso aqui que é questão da
imunização né então é não da Natural mas
a imunização artificial é natural que a
primeira pergunta que surge existe
vacina aqui ipox ela é eficaz existe
vacina nós não temos dados muit muito
assim sólido sobre a eficiência ou
eficácia H duas vacinas licenciadas nos
Estados Unidos para Monkey pox derivados
da vacina contra varíola humana Ou seja
é uma derivação de uma outro tipo de
vacina e essa vacina é aquela Ortodoxa é
aquela convencional não é da tecnologias
novas e nós sabemos que a varila humana
ela foi erradicada globalmente nas
décadas de 70 e 80 do século passado
então Eh essa vacina que tá disponível
ada dessa varíola do passado Ok e os
fabricantes é Sanofi e a Bavária
essas vacinas logicamente vão vender
essa ideia de que vão ser a principal
defesa contra a doença especialmente
para pessoas em grupos de risco e
profissionais de saúde que lidam
diretamente com casos suspeitos vamos
ver né o Quem viver verá a eficácia
disso né porém tem um uma um fator aí
alarmante né a produção dessas vacinas é
limitada então por exemplo uma das
vacinas licenciadas nos Estados Unidos
que é produzido pelo laboratório
bavarian nordic ela tem uma capacidade
de produção bem restrita então estima-se
que até o final de 2024 apenas cerca de
3 milhões de doses estarão disponíveis a
nível Global 3 milhões pro mundo inteiro
e esse número vai subir para 8 milhões
até o final de 2025 Ok o Brasil tem
acesso a uma vacina chamada gus né que é
da Bavaria nordic que eu já mencionei e
a
inamex que é produzida pela IDT
biológica Ok então segundo Anvisa ambas
essas eh
fabricantes tem as doses que se referem
ao mesmo produto com nomenclatura
diferente nos Estados Unidos e na Europa
Então esse volume é insuficiente para
cobrir a demanda Global especialmente
num continente populoso como a África
onde a vacinação poderia ser crucial
então em termos de eficácia o
laboratório Bavária
algo em torno de 85% isso aí é legação
do laboratório Ok não sabemos exatamente
se esses números são corretos ok porém
esses números são em cima da Cepa
anterior tá na 2B de bola né apesar de
ser agora 1b a anterior era 2B Ok então
ela foi testada nessa de 2 anos atrás
Então existe uma preocupação muito
grande que é com a escassez das vacinas
digamos assim tradicionais da tecnologia
antiga surge discussão sobre o uso
daquele outro tipo de material que
correu aí há 2 anos atrás 3 anos atrás 4
anos atrás né que ganhou
notoriedade durante o o período que nós
vivemos aí 4 anos atrás 3 anos atrás e
esse tipo de tecnologia né que nós estou
falando aqui de RNA mensageiro ela é
muito discutível Ok el e não posso ser
muito claro aqui vocês sabem porquê
então vai ser utilizado um argumento de
que o o RNA mensageiro Vai ser
necessário porque existe essa vantagem
de que vai poder vai poder ser produzido
em massa muito mais rapidamente mas a
aplicação eh para a doença mipox
obviamente vai gerar muito debate
especialmente em termos de eficácia e
segurança Ok há também preocupações
sobre a imposição né que nós vivemos
isso nos últimos anos em regiões onde a
produção da tecnologia tradicional vai
ser insuficiente está claro isso né
levantando várias questões aí que eu não
vou entrar em detalhes porque se não
quero que esse vídeo caia então Eh pode
acontecer muito provável uma imposição
de emergência Global como aconteceu H
alguns anos atrás induzindo o uso da
tecnologia do RNA mensageiro Ok eu não
posso ser muito específico sobre esse
assunto porque vocês sabem muito bem o
que que aconteceu há alguns anos atrás e
a minha visão sobre o tema que eh tentei
na época ser o mais direto com vocês o
possível mais sincero e isso prejudicou
bastante o canal e eu tô passando por um
momento hoje de shadan importante Ok
então a gente não pode entrar em
detalhes aqui quem quiser saber mais
sobre esse assunto do RNA vai ter que
entrar no meu canal do Rumble que hoje
em dia você sab que no Brasil para
acessar o Rumble você tem que ter uma
VPN né Eu acho que 80% do meu público
não sabe nem o que que é isso espero tá
errado mas enfim lá no Rambo vai ter
material sobre esse assunto tanto no meu
canal de lá quanto no canal de outros
produtores de conteúdo e como eu já
falei vocês vão precisar de uma VPN que
é uma rede privada virtual Private
Network eh isso não é complicado hoje em
dia tem que ter só um pouquinho de boa
vontade para instalar isso daí Porque
você sabe por decisões recentes aí
distâncias superiores eh o Brasil não
tem hoje o acesso livre ao Rumble Ok
Ah então no Brasil em 2022 teve uma
importação
emergencial de cerca de 56.000 doses da
vacina contra a varíola destinada a
Profissionais de Saúde e pessoas vivendo
com HIV e essas vacinas no entanto estão
sob regime de uso emergencial com uma
autorização provisória da Anvisa que foi
estendida até 2023 então Apesar de nós
estarmos em 2024 a a vacina convencional
essa que nós temos no Brasil em regime
emergencial ainda continua com essa
licença provisória o que levanta a
necessidade de mais dados sobre a sua
eficácia e segurança especialmente
contra atual C como eu falei a gente não
sabe da atual eficácia e segurança e
eficiência da tecnologia convencional
aplicada a essa Cepa atual só temos essa
esse dado de 85% do fabricante em
relação a Cepa anterior não sei se ficou
Claro para vocês ok
Eh vamos falar agora aqui do que é mais
importante as medidas que vocês podem
tomar para deixar os sistema imune de
vocês forte Ok fora aquela questão que
eu falei de lavar as mãos de passar
antisséptico nas mãos fora a questão de
você em alguns momentos em algumas
situações específicas utilizar máscara
ou um distanciamento da pessoa doente Ok
não tô falando distanciamento Geral
falando da distanciamento da pessoa
doente Ok então
Eh higiene pessoal e ambiente Então a
primeira linha de defesa nós já falamos
higiene pessoal lavar as mãos
frequentemente com água e sabão o usar
álcool em gel né que vocês já estão
cansado de saber evitar tocar o rosto
sem higienizar as mãos são medidas
importantes que valeram pra situação
anterior e vão valer eh pra situação
atual então é importante a crucial
evitar o contato próximo com pessoas que
apresente lesões cutâneas suspeitas tá
como discutimos eh o vírus pode ser
transmitido tanto por contato direto com
contato com superfícies contaminadas com
roupas e também em algumas situações até
pelo ar Ok então desinfetar regularmente
superfícies e roupas e que possam ter
sido expostas ao vírus é uma medida
preventiva muito importante Ok usar as
máscaras também em situações específicas
tá eu não tô aqui eh recomendando que
todo mundo saia por aí igual aconteceu
há três anos atrás só em situações que
você saiba que você tá em alto risco de
est contato com pessoas muito próximas a
você em ambientes fechados Ok ou
especialmente mal ventilados
ok para evitar que as Goías né que a
pessoa fala com você caia em cima de
você
[Música]
ã vamos também tomar cuidado com as
fontes de informação que a gente vai ter
acesso eh evitar notícias muito
sensacionalistas evitar Manchete
sensacionalistas evitar pessoas que vão
usar aí essa situação de saúde pública
para se autopromover então usar canais
confiáveis canais que queiram disseminar
conhecimento fundamental que vocês
sintam que não tem interesses eh por
trás que eu não vou entrar em detalhes
aqui para não atrapalhar esse vídeo ok
então medicina de estilo de vida
alimentação saudável canso de falar
sobre isso vamos manter uma alimentação
equilibrada rica em nutrientes essencial
pro funcionamento adequado do sistema de
defesa alimentos que são especialmente
anti-inflamatórios né algumas frutas
verduras antioxidantes vão ajudar a
reduzir inflamação crônica tem vídeos
reitos no canal assistam os os vídeos do
canal Pessoal vocês não vão ser
notificados então vocês T que entrar no
canal assim como eu faço com os
produtores de conteúdo que eu gosto eu
gosto de acompanhar eh muita coisa aí de
geopolítica internacional canais de
Economia canais sobre vários assuntos
diferentes e eu vou no canal da pessoa e
vejo os últimos vídeos que essa pessoa
postou eu não fico dependendo de eh
notificação então eu faço um apelo para
vocês aqui porque hoje tá muito
complicado você difundir informação de
qualidade no YouTube o YouTube tá muito
parecido hoje com tiktok em termos de
algoritmo então vocês entrem no canal
busc as informações que vocês queiram
nós estamos falando com muita frequência
sobre alimentação antioxidante
alimentação para melhorar o sistema
imune busca as informações no canal não
fique esperando a plataforma te oferecer
através do algoritmo porque tá muito
complicado hoje sobre isso tá então é
importante evitar alimentos
ultraprocessados ricos em açúcares
gorduras artificiais que são as gorduras
trans muito importante ter uma
alimentação mais natural possível
tirando o excesso carboidrato refinado
da sua alimentação fazer a atividade
física regular é muito importante tanto
aeróbica quanto exício de força é muito
importante para aumentar a circulação
sanguínea facilitar o transporte de
células imunológicas por todo o nosso
organismo obviamente que o excesso e
exercício também vai ser um problema
então cuidado com o overtrain porque o
excesso vai fazer cair o seu sistema de
defesa mas se feito de maneira adequada
o exercício regula os níveis de cortisol
que é hormônio de estresse vai ajudar
você a controlar o seu estresse ajudar a
melhorar o seu sono e pode também ajudar
a regular a sua imunidade Ok mesmo coisa
simples caminhadas de 20 minutos por dia
30 minutos por dia já faz muita
diferença não fica o dia inteiro sentado
no computador a cada uma hora tenta
fazer uma caminhada nem que seja de 1 2
minutos a cada hora que você esver
sentado gerencia o seu estresse né o
stresse crônico é um grande inimigo do
sistema de defesa imune ao inos de
estresse desregulam o cortisol tanto
jogam ali para cima quanto para baixo o
que pode suprimir a resposta imunológica
e aumentar Nossa vulnerabilidade a
várias infecções então práticas como
relaxamento meditação reza respiração
profunda
mindfulness são muito importantes para
reduzir o estresse e consequentemente
fortalecer nossas defesas faça uma reza
junto com mindfulness ou uma reza junto
com meditação Isso vai ser muito
importante para você se você não for
religioso só faça a meditação só faça o
relaxamento que junto com a atividade
física vai ser muito importante para
ajudar nas suas defesas né não precisa
nem dizer aqui que um sono de grande
qualidade é essencial pra Regeneração do
cérebro pra Regeneração do corpo pra
Regeneração do sistema imune de defesa
então durante o sono o corpo produz C
toxinas altamente benéficas né que são
proteínas que vão ajudar a combater
infecções vão regular a resposta de
defesa imune
Então 7 a 8 horas de sono por noite é
fundamental e vamos falar aqui dos
Suplementos tá antes dos Suplementos eu
queria falar de vocês uma nota rápida de
um assunto que eu fiquei sabendo hoje tá
fora o álcool gel aparentemente apareceu
um produto novo aí Eu não sei se é sua
propaganda não tô endossando esse
produto porque não conheço ainda Ok mas
está sendo divulgado aí na no Instagram
um produto chamado fita Cream tá que é
com ph PH itta PH e TTA Cream fita Cream
que é um seria um creme antisséptico
para mãos eu não sei se isso aqui É
vantajoso em relação a álcool Gel tá E
essa propaganda que tá sendo veiculada
aí eu acredito que seja uma propaganda
no Instagram teria demonstrado uma
eficácia na proteção contra o vírus do
mipox e teria sido submetido a estudos
né Eu entrei até no na pasta do Google
Drive que tá lá ah a documentação sobre
esses estudos não li muito detalhes mas
estes testes teriam sido feitos pelo
Instituto de Ciências biomédicas da
Universidade de São Paulo e CB USP e
esse produto poderia ter conseguido
inativar eliminar o mipox o vírus
responsável pela doença Ok o vírus
MPX V que é o vírus do mipox ok além das
variantes então ess aí um pequena nota
lateral aí então vamos cuidar Nossa
vitamina D de dáa mais importante a
vitamina C de casa o zinco esses sãoos
três principais que você tem que ficar
atento né Hoje é muito muito frequente
pessoas com deficiência de vitamina D
muito muito frequente pessoas com
deficiência de zinco então menam esses
exames tá são exames hoje que qualquer
plano de saúde cobre a vitamina C também
é importante e estudos já demonstraram
tá estudos que foram questionados mas
mostraram sim que a deficiência de
vitamina D é muito importante na na
questão aí de eh deixar a pessoa
vulnerável aos vírus em geral e no
Brasil mesmo sendo um país ensolarado um
país tropical tem tido muita deficiência
de vitamina D tá sendo muito comum mesmo
em Estados onde tem muita e incidência
solar Ok mesmo no nordeste mesmo no Rio
de Janeiro mesmo eh em estados que tem
muita insolação tá então é muito
importante você tá atento aos seus
níveis de vitamina D de vitamina C de
zinco e também usar todo o armamentário
natural que nós temos tá acetina é um
flavonoid que eu já falei em vários
vídeos é muito interessante é um
antioxidante natural encontrado em
alimentos como alcaparra cebola e maçã
ela tem eh grande utilização como
antiinflamatório também como
antistamínico tem propriedade também
antiviral eu passo paraos pacientes que
têm doenças virais de modo geral outros
suplementos tem muitos suplementos aqui
eu não vou entrar em extremos detalhes
aqui porque tem muitos vídeos no canal
quero que se vocês vão vão no canal e
procure os vídeos porque senão se vocês
não fizerem isso vocês vão ter
dificuldade porque a plataforma não está
avisando vocês tá dos vídeos OK então
outros suplementos que podem ser
considerados a cucumina
ômega-3 a equinas o própolis tá tem
várias substâncias naturais aí eu eu
diria para vocês sairem dessa Live
lembrando da que cetina da vitamina C da
vitamina D do zinco e do ômega3 ok para
não ficar muita informação na cabeça de
vocês a intenção é ser uma mini Live Eu
até tô me estendendo um pouquinho no
tempo que a ideia era expor esse
material em 20 minutos tá sobre as
moléculas reposicionadas aquelas que
foram tão polêmicas nos últimos 3 4 anos
nós acreditamos pelos dados que nós
temos disponíveis que elas também TM
ação antiviral contra o monkeypox eu não
posso mencionar aqui explicitamente Você
sabem por lembre-se das duas cantoras
famosas Ok a Ivete Sangalo e a Anita ok
lembra dessas duas cantoras aí que vocês
vão saber do que eu tô falando quando eu
falo de moléculas reposicionadas
Infelizmente aqui eu tenho que ser muito
cuidadoso parafraseando aí uma pessoa
que eu admiro muito o professor luí
Antônio pechou do Vale os bons
entendedores entenderão Ok eu sei que
assim não sendo muito claro eu prejudico
algumas pessoas que são mais Humildes
mas é o preço que eu pago para continuar
falando algumas coisas para vocês aqui
nesse canal Ok então assim não tem
nenhum antiviral licenciado que que tem
esse fim específico Ok embora as duas
cantoras tenham sido estudadas com algum
resultado favorável algum resultado
favorável gente então a gente não tem
ainda muitos dados ainda sólidos sobre
isso OK eu acredito que essas duas
cantoras poderiam funcionar porque há
por trás do mecanismo de ação desses eh
dessas moléculas reposicionadas eh que é
estimulando o ser humano a reagir contra
eh vários vírus diferentes Ok e de
estimular aí a especialmente a ação do
interferon Alfa no organismo tá porém a
gente não vai ter resultados de grandes
estudos vocês sabem por que que não vão
ter grandes estudos porque são fármacos
sem patent tá o que vai interessar mesmo
são as soluções que você sab que vão
oferecer aí se se acaso essa doença
digamos assim ficar pior né então existe
aí algumas drogas caríssimas e com
patente ainda que foram reposicionados
que não eram Originalmente PR mipox aí
não tô falando da Ivete e nem estô
falando da da Anita falando de drogas
que ainda não foram lançadas que aqui no
Brasil tem patente ainda são caras eh
então se você me perguntar existe um
antiviral licenciado para tatam pox não
não tem mas potencialmente as cantoras
aí podem ser utilizadas é importante que
seja caso a caso com o paciente com seu
médico o médico conversando com o
paciente numa conduta off Label né que
não está na bula pegando o termo de
consentimento livre esclarecido para que
ele possa concordar em participar em
Tomar essas moléculas reposicionadas que
não tem na bula a indicação Ok e se
houver essa concordância médico paciente
né E essas medicações esses essas
moléculas reposicionadas poderiam ajudar
nessa situação Então estou terminando
aqui a minha fala né sobre esse assunto
em resumo a prevenção contra monkeypox e
outras infecções virais depende o
conjunto de práticas que envolvam desde
a higiene básica até um estilo de vida
saudável então ao adotar essas medidas
você não só reduz o risco de contrair a
doença mas também melhora a sua saúde
geral ficando mais protegido contra uma
série de outras doenças Então veja os
meus vídeos sobre eh materiais Como
melhorar a imunidade tá veja meus vídeos
sobre vitamina C vitamina D própolis
cúrcuma
curcumina gengibre limão tá os vídeos
gerais sobre vitaminas e minerais Tá ok
vídeos aí que eu tenho postado nos
últimos 4 anos tá embora esses hábitos
não garantam Total imunidade eu nem tô
falando aqui para vocês que se vocês
tomarem vitamina C zinco que cetina
vocês estão totalmente protegidos n não
vão garantir Total imunidade mas vão
ajudar a reduzir a frequência e a
gravidade Ok então vou abrir aqui para
algumas perguntas de vocês só 10 minutos
de pergunta pessoal porque eu já
estourei o tempo aqui
eh Boa noite Maria Fátima Boa noite
Pedro Luiz Vera Lúcia
Boa noite a todos que estão acompanhando
ao vivo
eh pelo que eu li esta hipótese de
pandemia foi
descartada Tomara que você tenha razão
viu ô
APB Tomara que você tenha razão
ã Deus te
ouça aqui o Eliseu pessoas com imunidade
forte podem pegar podem mas a tendência
é que vão ter uma resposta muito mais
forte e vão conseguir sair muito melhor
da do desfecho da doença OK agora não
manifestar sintoma Com certeza todos os
vírus T essa característica vai ter
gente que vai contrair o vírus e não vai
desenvolver sintomas se tiver um sistema
imune eh bastante forte tem esse
comentário aqui da Maria de Fátima
eh que mais boa noite Estela Mares um
beijo para
você exatamente Maria de Fátima não
vamos baixar Nossa frequência mental com
medo isso é muito importante Ok
ah não sei te informar isso Eliseu Tá
mas isso é uma estratégia totalmente
válida para vírus em geral
ok Não não é isso isso aí eu tô
entendendo Onde você quer chegar existe
aí algumas suspeitas que eu não posso
falar aqui realmente por que esse esse
vírus se modificou tá bom basta dizer
isso hã
Então temos que ter cuidado em viagem
para o exterior os hotéis que não
higienizam direito sim se for um hotel
mais simples com certeza tá se ter que
procurar um hotel mais confiável digamos
assim né mas eu entendo a sua
preocupação realmente ela é válida viu
Sara então Eh então rut existe muitas
pessoas tem a versão sim eu não vou
entrar em detalhes por tá bom r Mas é
uma questão simbólica viu não sei se
você tá entendendo o que eu tô falando
Ahã isso aqui eu não vou poder comentar
Viu Marco
[Música]
perdão exatamente Maria de Fátima isso é
muito muito importante manter a vibração
elevada ficar eh com pensamento positivo
isso é muito muito importante
[Música]
tá olha Eh controlar o melhor possível
que você puder aticar e não usar imuno
supressores se você puder Angélica seria
minha recomendação para você
tá concordo com essa
observação isso a informação eu não
tenho para te dar elizu isso acho que
ninguém sabe exatamente quantas sessões
seriam eficazes tá obrigado pelo
comentário talvez mar de Fátima eu não
posso afirmar isso
eh tacitamente digamos assim
Boa pergunta Daniele Depende se você
tiver num ambiente fechado nesse país aí
eu usaria sim tá se for um ônibus se for
um trem se for uma um evento com muitas
pessoas eu usaria
Tá sim como eu comentei que cetina
vitamina C não falei do nac mas o nac
Com certeza ajudaria
tá isso
é Opa vamos dizer assim eu entendi o que
você tá querendo
dizer eu entendo o seu comentário Daila
eu acho que eh o que você tá pensando é
válido
tá Dependendo para onde você vai e como
as coisas vão acontecer nos próximos
meses eu usaria assim
Marco Exatamente
franceli isso daí o eu não posso
comentar aqui se vocês quiserem ver mais
detalhes disso lá no Rumble tá tem que
usar
VPN é mas paciência Kell Eh tá no jogo
né não não dê muita atenção para essas
pessoas né
é eu acho que vai gente vai ver um o
filme de novo Viu Maria de Fátima
Obrigado Sofia
Olha é só você colocar o meu nome no tá
aí em cima na tela tá o meu nome é lá em
Dutra no YouTube e procurar o meu canal
é o que eu faço com os canais que eu
costumo seguir porque se for depender de
aviso da plataforma vocês não vão ser
avisados
tá é mas nós precisamos informar as
pessoas Júlio eu entendo que você tá
querendo colocar aqui mas eu preciso
informar as pessoas
tá é possível sim Lia
sim Marco é uma é uma estratégia válida
tá Apesar de eu não ter informações aqui
específicas sobre mipox para isso daí
que você colocou aí
OK isso aqui o que o Eliseu tá colocando
Vocês que querem ter um contato mais
próximo comigo semanal com perguntas e
respostas eh se você se interessar por
ter esse contato semanal comigo eh
clique no botão seja membro aí que
aparece para você no celular aí embaixo
do do vídeo
eu acho estranho F ali porque eu tenho
pedido esse exame não tenho visto
negarem tá pode ser que o seu produto
específico seja mais um produto mais
barato digamos assim e tá tendo essa
esse problema não tenho visto isso na
prática não tá mas vale a pena pagar se
você puder
tá isso Sara é isso mesmo que eu peço
para vocês
fazerem
ok olha Franc usa o protocolo da doença
anterior tá até a gente ter mais mais
informações Ok eu tive um eu tive muito
problema de ficar repetindo a exaustão
como é que uso isso daí tá então não
posso mais falar disso tá Dá uma olhada
lá no no
Rumble é o que eu comentei Eu acho que
você não tinha não viu o pedaço que eu
falei né De
[Música]
nada que Deus também te abençoe
Então os sintomas graves seria a parte
da depressão sistema respiratório tá
essa que seria a parte mais
grave Ok Lia colocou a sua opinião aqui
de nada
Regina obrigado Elan pela pelas palavras
gentis deve ajudar Fabiana mas eu não
tenho dados específicos
Tá sim doras são para para tratamento tá
para tratamento podem ser utilizadas
como prevenção secundária tá e não vou
entrar em detalhes do que que é isso
para não confundir
vocês usa o protocolo
anterior
eh eu uso bastante na tokas tá concordo
Dr zebalo deve ter aprendido isso com a
gente da da integrativa né então tem
vários médicos não eram afinados com
essa medicina integrativa funcional que
aprenderam alguns truques conosco né
Eh eu uso bastante na toquin naac para
essas consequências que você tá
comentando aí
tá
ok Acho ótimo tá o
zcr eu não sei como é que fala o seu
nome certo desculpe
hã saudações ao
[Música]
Artur mesmo casquinha da sim a casquinha
carrega o vírus sim Exatamente isso
tá
É algumas pessoas vão ter problemas aí
não posso explicar por né mas realmente
tem muitas pessoas com imunidade
eh prejudicada aí vocês sabem que tem a
ver né com algumas coisas assim
né Tá vendo veira Lúcia veira Lúcia aí
dando uma opinião médica querida aí
amiga de quem teve na na frente aí de de
batalha
né sim se for um caso grave pode
acontecer
sim não sei ainda não temos essa
informação ainda viu ela eh tá
aumentando a a a a a a infectividade
dela tá aumentando agora não tenho essas
informações de comparativas para te
apresentar tá
bom não dá para usar tranquilamente
esses três juntos se você quiser não
vejo como problema
não não não tem nada a ver com os
bichinhos não tem a ver com mudanças do
vírus aí que a gente não sabe como é que
aconteceu exatamente
tá obrigado Marco aí o pessoal que se
interessar é só apertar no botão
Ok não necessariamente Eliseu isso é um
assunto um pouco polêmico Mas se a febre
não for tão alta até Concordo com você
mas se for uma febre febre muito alta eu
usaria e antitérmico
sim eu diria centenas né milhares eu
acredito que em casos pontuais
[Música]
né É É mais naa situação que você tá
colocando aí
sim Depende se a pessoa tiver o sistema
imune bom vai embora sozinho Sim ok
sim o que eu t comentando aqui Valera é
Unos vídeos que eu fiz na época de 3
anos atrás que eu tive tirar todos eles
da plataforma por causa do problema que
vocês sabem qual que é então se vocês
quiserem saber mais minha opinião sobre
outras situações que eu não posso falar
aqui vão lá no
rumble.com através do VPN tá vou colocar
rapidamente aqui o link para vocês deixa
eu achar aqui
mas tem que usar VPN tem que ser um
pouquinho descolado aí para poder usar o
vppn
Tá pera aí onde é que tá Tá
[Música]
aqui tá é o que tá aparecendo para vocês
aí rumble.com
baral Dutra tá eu acabei fazendo uma
live de quase 1 hora a ideia era fazer
30 minutos me estendi aqui pessoal Muito
obrigado pela audiência de vocês tá um
grande abraço um beijo no coração e até
a próxima tchau tchau